und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend ihnen wenn die Namen der
Regelungen allein ausschlaggebend wären
die die Bundesregierung heute auf ihrer
Klausurtagung präsentiert dann geht es
jetzt richtig los in Deutschland
wachstumsschancengesetz Bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz
zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz
allerdings gibt es ja schon länger die
Angewohnheit die erhoffte Wirkung eines
Gesetzes gleich in den Namen zu
schreiben das ist zunächst mal eine
politpr allein die Nennung des Gesetzes
soll Erfolg signalisieren ob es
tatsächlich im vorgesehenen Sinn Erfolg
hat ist damit noch lange nicht gesagt
aktuell hat die Regierungskoalition eine
schlechte wirtschaftliche Lage in
Deutschland erkannt sie spricht selbst
von Meter langen Aktenbergen und
Bürokratie Dickicht und verspricht jetzt
einen Turnaround Andreas Künast mit den
Details
als der Bundeskanzler gefolgt von Gepäck
für zwei Tage zu einem weiteren Versuch
eintrifft aus seiner Regierung ein Team
zu machen Sie ihn an den Kameras Scholz
Partner vorbei die Partner
spektakulärster Konflikte die
Familienministerin die das
wachstumsgesetz des Finanzministers
blockierte der Finanzminister der das
heizungsgesetz des Wirtschaftsministers
blockierte der Wirtschaftsminister der
das wachstumsgesetz des Finanzministers
zwar nicht blockiert aber als zu klein
kritisiert hat weil Scholz den
Dauerstreit zwischen FDP und Grünen
bisher nicht befrieden kann verlangt
seine Partei seit Tagen und Wochen das
etwas geräuschloser regiert wird diese
Sachen auch geräuschloser Verlauf
geräuschloser geräuschloser demonstrativ
geräuscharm und demonstrativ zufrieden
mit der Regierung ist in Meseberg nur
einer Olaf Scholz sehr beeindruckend und
Scholz die jüngsten Größe der Ampel
gutes Ergebnis gute Reform gutes
Miteinander wir haben eine sehr
erfolgreiche Leistungsbilanz im letzten
und diesem Jahr und es wäre natürlich
gut wenn alle mit ihren
Kommunikationsstrategien dazu beitragen
ich habe das Gefühl diese Klausur trägt
dazu bei dass das auch gut gelingen kann
schönen Dank für Fragen an die Regierung
ist heute keine Zeit Bilder von der
Regierung sind reichlich machbar
erfolgreiche Koalition im Schloss bei
der Arbeit nachdem die Wirtschaft seit
Monaten Alarm schlägt nachdem die
Verbände vor Abwanderung warnen wollte
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck dringend
Investitionsausgaben erhöhen und
Finanzminister Lindner dringend Steuern
senken der Mittelweg den die Regierung
heute beschließt führt zu
Steuerentlastungen aber zum Meer als
vorm Meseberg geplant das sogenannte
wachstumschancengesetz soll Unternehmen
von insgesamt sieben Milliarden Euro
entlasten jährlich bis
25 eine Prämie in Höhe von 15 Prozent
soll Investitionen in den Klimaschutz
belohnen für den Bau neuer Wohngebäude
sind massive Steuererleichterungen
geplant wenn das alles zusammenkommt
schaffen wir Impulse diese
Wachstumsschwäche schnell zu überwinden
und damit erleichtern wir für nahezu
alle Betriebe
nahezu alle privaten Investitionen den
Streit den es immer noch gibt zum
Beispiel über einen industriestrompreis
trägt die Ampel heute tatsächlich
geräuschloser aus aber morgen ist ja
auch noch ein Tag
Klaus Burgberg beobachtet die
Klausurtagung in Schloss Meseberg und
haben Klaus von
Wachstumschancen gesetzt da hören wir ja
schon länger von Digitalisierung
voranbringen und Bürokratie abbauen
hören wir Gefühl schon ewig was ist denn
jetzt wirklich neu an dem Paket
und neues Gefühl auch in dieser
Koalition also jenseits aller
polit-poesie mit schönen Namen die die
Gesetze dann bekommen würde man jetzt
hier drin wahrscheinlich auf diese Frage
hören als Antwort neu ist dass man nicht
nur darüber redet sondern dass man auch
tatsächlich etwas macht und als
Beispiele werden dann immer zum Beispiel
die LNG Terminals an der Nordseeküste
angeführt bei denen man die Planungszeit
etwa halbiert hat das ist diese
Deutschland Geschwindigkeit von der der
Kanzler dann immer wieder spricht oder
auch einfache Brückenbauten also wenn
Brücken aus den 50ern ersetzt werden
müssen dann sollen sie nicht so gebaut
werden müssen wie damals sondern
angepasst werden können auf Verkehr von
heute und morgen ohne dass man komplett
die Planung nochmal das sind so
Beispiele wo man versucht schneller zu
werden ohne anderen Substanz zu
verlieren muss man sozusagen und wie
geht's jetzt ganz konkret weiter wo
liegen in dieser Koalition der
Fallstrecke die Fallstrecke
also morgen geht es mit einer regulären
Kabinettssitzung weiter da wird dann
also erstmal festgezurrt was hier in
Meseberg beschlossen wurde aber auch
einige andere Dinge aber Fallstricke
gibt es natürlich trotzdem nicht
unbedingt jetzt bei denen die hier
vielleicht heute abend gerade im
Schlosskeller oder so sitzen sondern
wenn dieses Gesetz das jetzt von der
Regierung im Kabinett dann vorgeschlagen
wird auf dem Weg gebracht wird ins
Parlament muss es gibt bei einigen Probe
bevor haben auch Vorbehalte der
jeweiligen Fraktion und es gibt
natürlich die Oppositionen es gibt das
Druckstücke Gesetz dem zufolge kein
Gesetz so in den Bundestag reinigt raus
aus dem Bundestag rauskommt wie es
reingegangen ist und nach all dem was im
Parlament passiert reden auch die Länder
noch mit der Bundesrat muss zustimmen
und auch da hat die Opposition großes
Gewicht also es gibt noch sehr sehr
viele Hürden zu überwinden bis diese
Gesetze in welcher Form und in welcher
mit welcher Veränderung auch immer dann
tatsächlich wirksam in Kraft treten
können das Druckstücke Gesetz mit
universeller Gültigkeit Klaus herzlichen
Dank nach Meseberg ja und dann gibt es
einen Streit Thema auf das guckt die
deutsche Wirtschaft heute ganz besonders
dass das Thema hochumstritten ist ist
durchaus verständlich denn es geht um
wirklich viel Geld dutzende Milliarden
die Frage lautet soll der Staat sprich
die Steuerzahler sprich wir alle
Unternehmen unterstützen die viel
Energie brauchen und für die in
Deutschland sehr hohen Stromkosten
subventionieren die Koalition ist da
gespalten FDP dagegen grüne dafür
SPD-Kanzler eher dagegen SPD-Fraktion
dafür soll es einen
industriestrompreis geben Pro und Kontra
jetzt von Laura barnick und Christian
Kirsch
[Musik]
derzeit sind die enormen Strompreise
eines der größten Probleme für die
deutsche Wirtschaft Lösungsvorschlag ein
staatlich subventionierter
industriestrompreis zwischen 5 und 6
Cent pro Kilowattstunde
es gibt zwei zentrale Gründe für den
industriestrompreis einerseits geht es
um Unternehmen die heute schon sehr viel
Strom verbrauchen die haben ein riesiges
Kostenproblem und drohen abzuwandern in
andere Länder wo die Strompreise
niedriger sind zum anderen geht es um
Transformation viele Unternehmen
produzieren heute noch mit fossilen
Energien etwa mit Gas die wollen sich
elektrifizieren also wollen die
Produktionsprozesse auf Strom umstellen
aber diese Investitionen werden nur dann
passieren in Deutschland wenn es
Verlässlichkeit gibt bei den
Strompreisen wie es soll nur die großen
Betriebe unterstützt werden kleinere
Firmen gucken in die Röhre viel Geld für
bald veraltete industriestrompreis
wird alte Strukturen zementieren er wird
energieintensive Produktion in
Deutschland fördern damit nicht zu
Energieeinsparung führen er wird die
Einhaltung der Klimaschutzziele 2030
schwieriger machen und da wird auch
verhindern dass neue Ideen neue Produkte
Innovation und Energieeffizienz sich
durchsetzen okay okay aber hier geht es
doch nur um ein paar Jahre bis die
erneuerbaren Energien stark genug sind
quasi eine übergangsstrategie die
erstmal darauf basiert die erneuerbaren
Energien ganz stark auszubauen damit die
Strompreise von alleine wieder sinken
das wird auch passieren aber das wird
doch einige Zeit dauern und der
industriestrompreis der
brückenstrompreis der greift ab heute
und bietet den Unternehmen
Planungssicherheit schön und gut von
wegen Überbrückung aber staatlich
subventionierte industriestrompreise
werden alle zur Kasse bitten
wir haben im Augenblick ein
angebotsproblem das heißt der Preis wird
dann steigen und letztlich alle
VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher alle
Unternehmen diesen industriestrompreis
nicht bekommen werden mehr Geld für den
Strom zahlen und damit werden die
Unternehmen die ihn nicht erhalten im
globalen Wettbewerb weniger
wettbewerbsfähig werden also es ist ein
sehr hoher Preis für alle anderen die
diesen industriestrompreis nicht
erhalten der schnelle Ausstieg aus der
Atomkraft könnte uns teuer zu stehen
kommen aber warum hat der Staat dann
durch den Atomausstieg der Stromangebot
erste reduziert um jetzt eine
Subventionierung zu bieten Atom hat am
zum Zeitpunkt des Ausstiegs nur noch
sechs Prozent der Stromerzeugung
ausgemacht
man hätte es vielleicht verlängern
können aber realistischerweise hätte das
eben genießen man hätte neue Brennstäbe
bestehen bestellen müssen und hätte sich
dann über wahrscheinlich zehn Jahre oder
länger wieder an die Antrum Energie
gebunden das war politisch aber nicht
gewollt jetzt ist es wie es ist
energieintensive Industrie wird von der
Unterstützung profitieren Zahlen werden
aber alle anderen ein
industriestrompreis bedeutet dass 90%
der deutschen Wirtschaft deutlich höhere
Stromkosten haben werden weil die werden
dafür zahlen müssen nicht nur durch
steuerliche Transfers sondern letztlich
auch wenn die Stromkosten höher für alle
anderen sein das heißt der
industriestrompreis wird die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft als Ganzes er schädigen
am Industriestrom scheiden sich halt die
Geister die Debatte wird die Politik
weiter unter Spannung halten
unser nächstes Thema heute abend Bayerns
Ministerpräsident Markus Söder ist in
der Hochphase des Wahlkampfs um sein Amt
39 Tage noch bis zur Entscheidung im
Freistaat das Allerletzte was er jetzt
braucht ist eine Affäre um ein
widerliches Flugblatt in der es
drängende Fragen gibt an Söders
Koalitionspartner und Stellvertreter
Hubert Aiwanger das der Zeitpunkt extrem
ungünstig ist hat Söder heute selbst
gesagt und ansonsten eine interessante
Strategie gewählt während viele
Beobachter für Söder zwei mögliche
Optionen sahen Aiwanger feuern oder mit
ihm weitermachen beide aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen für den
CSU-Chef hochproblematisch Welt Söder
heute einen dritten Weg er verschafft
sich Zeit und erhöht gleichzeitig den
Druck auf Aiwanger der muss jetzt über
25 Fragen brüten die er seine
Ministerpräsidenten schriftlich
beantworten soll Stefan Seifert
als sich die Scheinwerfer am Morgen auf
Münchens Staatskanzlei richten beginnt
ein Tag an dem es kein einziges Bild von
Hubert Aiwanger geben wird nach über
vier Stunden Krisensitzungen kommt
Markus Söder alleine zur Presse ein
kurzes Statement nur nachfragen
unerwünscht Söder beginnt mit maximaler
Distanzierung das heads Flugblatt ist
ekelhaft widerlich
es ist übelster nazischargon
so wie das Flugblatt auch geschrieben
ist merkt man dass da auch eine ganz
andere Energie dahinter steckt das ist
nicht nur ein dummer Jungenstreich oder
eine bloße Jugendsünde
ist einfach ernst und sichtlich
angespannt erklärt Söder noch viele
Fragen zu haben es ist kein Freispruch
aber auch keine Vorverurteilung die
heutigen Aussagen reichen aber nicht aus
definitiv nicht aus für eine
abschließende Bewertung und Klärung es
blieben und bleiben viele Fragen offen
Aiwanger bekommt Aufschub es ist auch
eine Machtdemonstration des CSU-Chefs 25
Fragen zu Urheberschaft und Verbreitung
des Holocaust verhöhnenden Flugplatz
soll Aiwanger beantworten die
Enthüllungen der Süddeutschen Zeitung
ließen da Lehrstellen ein Ultimatum gibt
es nicht ich hätte erwartet dass
Ministerpräsident Söder jetzt rein Tisch
macht stattdessen scheint er auf Zeit zu
spielen jetzt ist es richtig dass der
Bayerische Landtag des Heftes Handelns
in die Hand nimmt hier muss Hubert
Aiwanger jetzt dreht und Antwort stehen
und auch mit den Vorwürfen wirklich
aufräumen es geht jetzt nicht um
Wahlkampf es geht nicht um Koalitionen
sondern es geht darum wirklich dass wir
Schaden vom Freistaat Bayern abwenden im
Zusammenhang mit diesem furchtbaren
naziflugblatt so das Vize ab nun
Minister auf Bewährung das Söder an
Aiwanger festhält mehr machttaktik als
Überzeugung Söder braucht die Freien
Wähler notfalls auch ohne ihre
gayionsfigur Koalitionen hängen übrigens
auch nicht an einer einzigen Person es
gibt mit oder ohne eine Person im
Staatsamt ganz genau so eine Trennung
von Aiwanger birgt Risiken für Söder die
CSU hört grad viel ins Wahlvolk hinein
und empfängt gemischte Signale ganz
ehrlich das ist 35 Jahre her und
irgendwie muss man auch mal die Kirche
im Dorf lassen ich bin selber über die
Freien Wähler wir werden weiterhin dann
einen Rücken stärken natürlich
geschrieben hat dann muss wieder neu
debattiert werden aber so finde ich
würde dich das jetzt mal gut sein lassen
herzlichen Dank so dass Koalition geht
mit schwerer Hängepartie in die heiße
Wahlkampfphase fünfeinhalb Wochen vor
der Landtagswahl ist die Ausgangslage
offener als Söder lieb sein kann
Ursula Mönch ist Direktorin der Akademie
für politische Bildung in Tutzing am
schönen Starnberger See und forscht seit
Jahren über das Innenleben der CSU Frau
Professorin guten Abend guten Abend wie
viel Zeit hat sich denn Markus Söder
heute verschafft bis nach der Wahl wird
er wohl kaum warten können bis dann die
Antworten kommen oder nein er hat ja
auch Aiwanger aufgegeben dass er diese
Fragen erstens umfassend und zweitens
auch schnell beantworten möge also da
kann es sich ja wohl nur um ein paar
Tage handeln und wie geht's dann weiter
wie will denn so der entscheiden ob die
Fragen dann zu seiner Zufriedenheit
beantwortet worden sind
also da wird es wohl um eine stimmige
Argumentation gehen die da ist die eine
oder andere offene Stelle noch wo man
nicht genau weiß was hat jetzt
eigentlich Aiwanger selbst tatsächlich
getan welche Rolle spielte der Bruder
wenn das einigermaßen schlüssig erklärt
ist und vor allem ich gehe auch davon
aus dass ihm auch ein Bekenntnis ja zur
gegen Rechtsextremismus gegen
Verharmlosung von Nationalsozialismus
dass ihm das abgefordert wird nochmals
abgefordert wird und wenn das alles
stimmig ist ja dann ist das
voraussichtlich doch die Ausgangslage um
eine Koalition anzukündigen dass man die
wieder eingehen können mit einem
eiwanger in der Staatsregierung mit
einem einfacher in der Staatsregierung
wird denn dann noch was bleiben auch was
möglicherweise an Markus söderhaftet
oder ist die Sache wäre die dann in
diesem Fall vom Tisch
also genau das ist meines Erachtens
diese Aufgabe dieses Fragenkatalogs und
der Antworten darauf dass die CSU sich
also sicherstellen möchte dass da nichts
hängen bleibt also einerseits an den
Freien Wählern als Koalitionspartner
aber vor allem an der CSU also im Grunde
geht es darum sich selber auch
abzusichern das ist das eine Motiv
meines Erachtens dieses Fragenkatalog
und das andere Motiv ist auch so ein
Machtspiel zwischen den beiden dann zu
zeigen wird die CSU wir sind diejenigen
die darüber entscheiden ob wir diese
Koalition eingehen und ob Hubert
Aiwanger dabei sein darf man hat auch so
ein bisschen den Eindruck heute der
Ministerpräsident versucht sich so als
eine Art unabhängiger Richter zu
positionieren und eben nicht abhängig zu
sein von der Berichterstattung der
Süddeutschen Zeitung
ja was man ja auch verstehen kann also
die Berichterstattung der Süddeutschen
Zeitung ist durchaus auch umstritten da
gibt es Leute die sagen das ist im
Grunde so eine Art verdachtsbericht
Erstattung und er möchte dass jetzt
nicht sich zu sehr zu eigen machen und
sich im Grunde dann ja auch dem Urteil
der Medien zu sehr ausliefern aber
natürlich wird auch die Rezeption dieses
Antwort Katalogs er wird sicherlich auch
eine Rolle spielen
Koalitionen hängen nicht an einer
einzelnen Person hat Markus Söder heute
gesagt gilt das auch für die Freien
Wähler oder anders gefragt lassen die
sich denn von der Person einwanger
trennen das ist genau die Schwierigkeit
ich meine natürlich die CSU und Markus
Söder könnten sagen wir gehen die
Koalition mit den Freien Wählern ein
aber Hubert Aiwanger wird nicht Teil
dieser Staatsregierung sein das ist ja
grundsätzlich möglich als Vorbedingung
für Koalitionsverhandlungen aber damit
geht man natürlich ein großes Risiko als
CSU ein es ist davon auszugehen dass die
Freien Wähler ihrem Hubert Aiwanger
weiterhin treu bleiben werden dann würde
er weiterhin Parteivorsitzender bleiben
wäre nicht in die kabinettsdisziplin
eingebunden das könnte unter Umständen
das viel größere Problem werden jetzt
gucken wir was wir auf diese Koalition
auch auf die Stimmung innerhalb der
Koalition so ein Fragenkatalog ist ja
schon einigermaßen einzigartig und unter
Koalitionären Söder hat heute gesagt
jetzt darf aber wirklich nichts mehr
dazu kommen das kann man ja auch als
klare Ansage deuten dass seine Geduld
schwindet jetzt hat würde natürlich das
Problem dass er andere
Koalitionsoptionen insbesondere mit den
Grünen z.B ausgeschlossen hat Recht sich
das jetzt für ihn weil es einfach seine
Option beschränkt
ja natürlich das ist eine ganz massive
Einschränkung der Optionen andererseits
ist es natürlich er will sicher seinen
Vorteil sein argumentativen Vorteil
bewahren Markus Söder und die CSU und
diese argumentative Vorteil ist eben
sich weiterhin an der amperegierung im
Bund abarbeiten zu können indem er
argumentiert wir sind der ampelfreie
Süden und das könnte er nicht wenn er
die Freien Wähler nicht hätte hätte Frau
Professorin herzlichen Dank heute Abend
wieder für ihre Expertise danke schön
dass sie was
und das Gespräch aber aus Termin Gründen
kurz vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet so
jetzt gucken wir auf weitere wichtige
Nachrichten heute beginnen in der
deutschen Politik mit dir Christopher
die rund fünfeinhalb Millionen Bezieher
von Bürgergeld sollen ab dem kommenden
Jahr spürbar höhere Leistungen erhalten
das hat bundessozialminister Heil
bekannt gegeben
alleinstehende bekommen statt 502 Euro
ab Januar 563 Euro pro Monat insgesamt
handelt es sich um eine Erhöhung von gut
12 Prozent sagte der SPD Politiker
gerade in Krisenzeiten müsste man sich
auf den Sozialstaat verlassen können so
heilen
und auch der Mindestlohn in der
Altenpflege wird ab Februar deutlich
steigen und bis zu 14 Prozent
Arbeitsminister Heil wird eine
entsprechende Empfehlung der
pflegekommission umsetzen betroffen sind
etwa 1,3 Millionen Beschäftigte demnach
soll der Mindestlohn je nach
Qualifikation in zwei Stufen steigen
20,50€ pro Stunde sollen dann voll
ausgebildete Pflegefachkräfte verdienen
das Oberlandesgericht München hat die
Haftstrafe der bereits verurteilten
is-rückkehrerin Jennifer W auf 14 Jahre
erhöht anders des neuen Prozesses war
ein Antrag der Bundesanwaltschaft die
Richter sahen ist als erwiesen an dass
die Angeklagte tatenlos zugesehen hatte
als ihr Mann im Irak ein versklavtes
jesidisches Mädchen ankettete und in der
Hitze sterben ließ Jennifer Weg kann
gegen das Urteil noch Revision einlegen
Luftverschmutzung ist laut einer Studie
der Universität Chicago der
gefährlichste äußere Faktor für unsere
Gesundheit Feinstaub verkürzte die
weltweite Lebenserwartung um
durchschnittlich 2,3 Jahre so die
Forscher am stärksten betroffen sein
Länder in Südasien etwa Indien oder
Bangladesch dort könne die
Lebenserwartung bei besserer
Luftqualität um fast 7 Jahre steigen
insgesamt sei die Feinstaubbelastung
weltweit sehr ungleich verteilt
wir werden möglicherweise nie
zweifelsfrei erfahren was wirklich
passiert ist mit dem Flugzeug in dem der
russische Söldner Boss Jewgeni
bregoschin abstürzte und mit ihm die
gesamte Führungsmannschaft seiner Wagner
Privatarmee wir werden möglicherweise
nicht mal zweifelsfrei wissen ob er es
wirklich war den russlandsbehörden als
tot melden und es sagt ja sehr viel über
die aktuelle Situation im Reich des
Wladimir Putin dass wir wohl auch nie
hundertprozentig sicher sein können ob
da heute tatsächlich Brie Gosch ins
Leiche begraben wurde abgeschirmt in
einer Ecke eines Friedhofs in St
Petersburg klar ist es war kein Staat
sagt kein ehrenvolles Abschied nehmen
sondern eher das Gegenteil verheimlicht
merkwürdig auf jeden Fall Sebastian
keine Trauernden Anhänger kein
Staatsbegräbnis keine Heldenverehrung
nur diese Aufnahmen veröffentlicht von
einem Polizei in einem telegram Account
sie sollen das Grab von Jeff gehen auf
dem Friedhof zeigen der Friedhof selbst
ist abgeriegelt Friedhof geschlossen
wegen der Öffnungszeiten
die Beisetzung von mittags im kleinsten
Familienkreis statt Medien waren nicht
beim Begräbnis der Grund gezielte
Falschinformationen Journalisten wurden
zum 20 Kilometer entfernten seventeile
Friedhof gelockt
dort wurde öffentlich und begleitet von
Kameras der Wagner logistik-chef valeric
Carl auf beerdigt der auch bei dem
Absturz gestorben war
es scheint als wollte man verhindern was
sich in den vergangenen Tagen vor der
Wagner zentrale abgespielt hat
Heldenverehrung für einen Aufständischen
Natalia ist extra aus der Nähe von
Moskau nach St Petersburg gefahren und
pregorian und den anderen Wagner Leuten
zu gedenken für sie waren die Männer
Helden
oh junge meine Meinung ist dass das
natürlich ein Mord war es war auf keinen
Fall ein Unglück wir werden aber niemals
erfahren was passiert ist
Jungs waren professionelle Militärs an
denen es dem Verteidigungsministerium
mangelt man hätte sich an ihnen
orientieren müssen wenn jetzt aber die
Gruppe Wagner auseinanderfällt wird dies
für Russland eine große Verfehlung sein
ein Unglück
morgen soll der Friedhof für alle
geöffnet sein dann werden wohl auch die
wagner-anhänger zu dem grabpilgern
Bilder die der Kreml heute offenbar
vermeiden wollte
Friedhof geschlossen wegen der
Öffnungszeiten Armin Körper ist in St
Petersburg guten Abend Armin eine
Beisetzung als Versteckspiel quasi warum
das und wer steckt dahinter
allein die Tatsache dass hier bei mir
auf dem Schlossplatz von St Petersburg
heute abend business as usual herrscht
zeigt dass der ganze Arbeit geleistet
hat denn ich bin mir sicher dass man
dort heute nichts im Zufall überlassen
hat auch die russischen Staatsmedien
haben so gut wie gar nicht über die
Beisetzung berichtet wir hatten ja auch
praktisch keine Bilder dahinter steckt
das mit Jewgeni prigossin ein Mann zu
Grabe getragen wurde der von vielen
Russen verehrt wird von vielen im Westen
als vermeintlicher Kriegsverbrecher
gebrannt wird und von Wladimir Putin
selbst noch vor gut einem Jahr mit dem
höchsten Orden des Landes ausgezeichnet
wurde dass man den so haben die still
und leise begraben hat das zeigt wie
professionell das hier läuft und wir
nehmen die Russen das auf aramien ist da
viel Trauer zu spüren im Land aktuell
oder eher so eine Art Achselzucken
ich denke man muss das in einem Kontext
sehen dieses Land lebt ja seit über 20
Jahren unter einer Regierung die die
Zügel immer straffer angezogen hat die
Wagner Leute und ihre Sympathisanten mit
denen ich in den letzten Tagen hier
gesprochen habe bei denen hat man eine
starke Verunsicherung gemerkt es weiß ja
von denen niemand wie es mit der
Organisation und den Männern jetzt
weitergeht die Bevölkerung in Russland
die damit nicht direkt was zu tun hat
die kennt vor allem ihre Geschichte in
der ist ja immer Episoden gab wo Freund
und Feind gleichermaßen nicht vor ähm
vor Bedrohung und Verfolgung durch das
Regime gefallen waren die Menschen
gucken Weg sie denken sich ihren Teil
und das zeigt das ja einfach auch Angst
herrscht am Körper live aus der
prachtvollen Kulisse von St Petersburg
Armin herzlichen Dank
und wir gucken jetzt hier an die Börse
mit dir Christopher
über das Thema Industriestrom haben wir
ja schon ausführlich berichtet aber um
Strom geht es natürlich auch bei der
E-Mobilität und die nimmt in Deutschland
noch immer nicht so richtig Fahrt auf
fragen wir nach bei Stefanie Barrett
bislang dachte man ja oft das würde
hauptsächlich an der zu geringen Zahl an
Ladesäulen liegen da stand aber gar
nicht der Hauptgrund zu sein ja
tatsächlich legen überraschende Zahlen
einer Studie nahe das Besitzer von
Elektroautos hierzulande doch eine
komfortable Zahl an freien Ladestellen
Ladesäulen ansteuern können mit etwas
mehr als 100.000 öffentlichen
Ladepunkten bewegt sich Deutschland
sogar deutlich oberhalb der EU-Vorgaben
Gedränge herrschte auch nicht je nach
Landkreis ergab sich über den Tag eine
Belegung von maximal 25 %. das Ziel der
Bundesregierung bis 2030 insgesamt eine
Million öffentlicher Ladepunkte
bereitzustellen ist damit womöglich auch
technisch überholt denn inzwischen hat
die Ladeleistung einen riesigen Sprung
gemacht es können einfach mehr Fahrzeuge
Jesus Ladesäule mit Strom versorgt
werden stellt sich die Frage woran liegt
es denn dann dass ich immer noch mehr
Kunden für Autos mit Verbrennermotor als
für E-Autos entscheiden also nach wie
vor fehlen einfach im massensegment
kleine bezahlbare Stroma die deutschen
Angebote fehlen dazu Schrecken lange
Lieferzeiten ab die Reichweiten der
Batterien steigen zwar verlässlich doch
jetzt locken Hersteller von Verbrennern
sogar mit saftigen Rabatten auf die 30
meistverkauften verbrennermodelle gab es
im August einen durchschnittlichen
Nachlass von fast 18 Prozent so hoch
waren Rabatte zuletzt vor zwei Jahren
gleichzeitig fahren Hersteller ihre
Rabatte für E-Autos deutlich zurück und
wenn im kommenden Jahr die staatliche
Förderung für Privatkäufer auf 3000 €
singt dann dürfte ein weiterer Kauf
Anreiz verschwinden vielen Dank nach
Frankfurt stefanit
das Ermittlungsverfahren gegen Rammstein
Sänger Till Lindemann ist eingestellt
worden die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft
teilte dazu mit es gebe keine
Anhaltspunkte das Lindemann sexuelle
Handlungen an Frauen gegen deren Willen
vorgenommen habe
Opfer oder Zeugen hätten sich nicht
gemeldet oder sei nicht auffindbar
gewesen Mitte Juni hatten mehrere Frauen
Lindemann beschuldigt sie bei Partys
nach Rammstein Konzerten sexuell
belästigt zu haben
bei der Basketball WM hat die deutsche
Mannschaft im japanischen Okinawa auch
ihr letztes Vorrundenspiel gewonnen und
damit den dritten Sieg in Folge
eingefahren gegen Finnland setzte sich
die Mannschaft um Superstar Dennis
Schröder klar mit 101 zu 75 durch schon
zuvor hatte sich das Team für die zweite
Gruppenphase qualifiziert das nächste
Spiel der Deutschen ist dann am Freitag
der truppenstuben Sturm idea hat sich im
Golf von Mexiko zu einem Hurrikan
entwickelt und wird laut Wetterexperten
auf seinem Weg Richtung Florida heute
Nacht weiter an Stärke gewinnen Florida
bereitet sich auf den Sturm vor für 46
Bezirke hat es vorsorglich den Notstand
erklärt in der kubanischen Hauptstadt
Havanna sorgte edelia für heftigen Regen
und Wind in einigen Provinzen kam es zu
Stromausfällen und Überschwemmungen
Bewohner sein in Sicherheit gebracht
worden
so damit sagen wir zwei hier Danke fürs
Interesse jetzt gleich nach uns 37 Grad
und wir sehen uns wieder zum heute schon
mal Update wenn Sie mögen gegen 0 Uhr
Wir freuen uns auf DICH danke
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend zum Wetter
nach den kühlen letzten Tagen wird es
jetzt zumindest im Süden wieder etwas
sommerlicher der Temperatur Trend für
Stuttgart zeigt uns hier am Samstag um
die 27 Grad im Norden da bleiben die
Temperaturen aber weiter moderat hier am
Beispiel von Hamburg da bleiben wir so
um die 20 Grad der Dauerregen der in den
Alpen jetzt diese extremen Regenmengen
brachte lässt langsam nach die
entsprechende tiefdruckzentren hier
verlagern sich nach Osten es steht aber
schon ein neues Tief in den Startlöchern
über der Nordsee und dieses Tief bringt
uns jetzt morgen aus Nordwesten Schauer
und kurze Gewitter heute Nacht kühlt es
erst einmal ab auf 14 Grad direkt an der
See und 8 Grad in der Eifel und auch an
den Alpen und an den Alpen regnet es
heute Nacht noch am längsten oberhalb
von 2000 Metern schneit es auch noch
weiter sonst gibt es viele Wolken wo es
auf glatt bildet sich auch mal Nebel
morgen Vormittag lässt dann der letzte
Regen an Oder und Neiße und im südo nach
dann ist es erstmal weitgehend trocken
und wechselnd bewölkt aber es kündigt
sich eben im Westen und Nordwesten mit
ersten Schauern schon die Front dieses
neuen Tiefs an und das kann dann auch
nachmittags im Westen mal zu kräftigerem
Regen führen zumal sich da auch
vorlaufend hier über der Mitte schon
Schauer und kurze Gewitter bilden je
weiter wir morgen dann Richtung Osten
und Richtung Süden schauen desto ruhiger
wird der Tag nachmittags die
Temperaturen sind immer noch gedämpft
bei 16 Grad an den Alpen und 22 Grad am
Rhein zum Wochenende steigen zumindest
im Süden die Temperaturen und die
sonnenanteile wieder an in der Mitte und
im Norden kann es aber wechselhaft
bleiben und damit auf Wiedersehen